once you once you knowingly do something  criminal hell yeah you know how you're  involved in that life and you got to  know what that [ __ ] comes with right  period now if you're so that's called  accountability  and i don't even [ __ ] with people who  aren't accountable in the real normal  life yeah in normal life let alone when  people's lives are on the line  and you sending [ __ ] to jail  because you're not accountable for your  actions [ __ ] out of it scum of the earth  there it is he's a broken man he i mean  you know i'm saying like you you got  broken you  you let them people break you  i said tell me i got homies doing  natural life right now but they're not  broken they can look in the mirror  every day  still call me in high spirits type [ __ ]